I recently got another breast thermogram done. It's my first sense the full body was done at the
clinic two years ago. The full thermogram two years ago did not show any activity. The breast
I was told that this was because frequently my type of cancer will not show up on a thermogram.
Yes, that's true. This most recent thermogram, however, did show activity at the tumor site.
Is this necessarily vascular activity that is feeding the cancer? Is it possible that it's
inflammation related to topically applying frankincense at the end of a cell every day?
So what we'll show up on a thermogram is metabolic activity. So metabolic activity can be
cell growth and replication cells. That's going to increase metabolic activity and in any
increase in metabolic activity is going to increase heat. So what a thermogram is reading is heat.
Now, thermograms have negatives to them too. So some breast cancers don't replicate quickly.
Therefore, don't produce a lot of heat. Some cancers, not breast cancer, are too deep to actually
have the heat be expressed on the surface of the body. Therefore, you can't really see about a
thermogram. So it's not highly beneficial for a colon cancer or something.
But increased vascularization could increase heat. So that's a possibility.
But certainly doing anything topical on the skin is going to increase heat. So in this case,
I would say, you know, if you have been applying frankincense and DMSO on a daily basis,
I'd say you got about 99% chance. That's what it's fun. Now, if you really wanted to test it,
you'd stop doing that for, you know, a period of time. And it's an insurgent period of time,
because you don't know how long that that's going to take. But at least two weeks before doing it on
the thermogram. But that would be one way to test it.